foreign
Hunters
Bandits corporations
and nobody loser tapes
well you don't know skag diddly take
Promethea for example
a civilized place as far as planetary
sized piles of excrement call a planet
still recovering from its wall with a
malleable cooperation
the Rival Atlas Corporation is in bad
shape Rhys strong Fork the big shot CEO
with the regrettable mustache is
scrambling he's on the cusp of something
big
but he's not the only one
and into this pressure cooker steps Dr
anuradhar genius inventor socially
awkward day do gooder type
she works for Atlas been tinkering with
a big award-winning idea
her brother Octavio wallistar Meridian
City's most well-known man at least in
his own mind he's convinced his big
brick is just around the corner and
Fran miskowitz purveyor of restrung
Folk's favorite Frogger flavor
she's hoping for the big insurance pay
off after that regrettable malawan laser
incident
so you're probably asking yourself what
makes these three so special
and the answer is nothing
yet
you're free now
go
copy Free Run
morning what oh I mean
good morning
seriously
again yep another busy day work work
work am I right
by channeling the iridium's energy
through a multi-phasic refraction lens I
can reproduce the as yet inexplicable
powers of the sirens maybe not the wings
thing which is so cool but crucially the
ability to manipulate an object safely
through space-time
I'm Anu the ultimate siren fangirl but
for totally scientific reasons I swear
and I'm so close to replicating the
signature move of my all-time favorite
siren Lilith
R.I.P Ong
Anu
as I was saying
in addition to Forever altering the
nature of conflict vis-a-vis offering a
non-lethal resolution my device could
also change the world
for the better
imagine a way for people to solve their
problems without killing each other I
literally can't I just have to figure
out how to actually bring back the
objects I faced away and also where they
go and also what happens to them simple
interdepartmental demonstrations
scheduled for two weeks from today Dr
anuradhar signing off
oh snap two weeks really it's going to
be ready by then
it is or it will be
two weeks is enough time for a huge
breakthrough right
probably right sure
I should have said three months what was
I thinking
all I've got to do is just figure out
the next step that's it
there's got to be something I'm missing
figure it out with like your Intuition
or with your Tech goggles I would like
to think both
maybe start with the tuck goggles though
there's a button on the side
okay goggles
let's try a diagnostic
so for starters I should probably put an
actual power source in there huh
you needed the goggles for that now
where did I put that iridium or
thank you
[Music]
I don't know why I ever thought a
jaberman translator was a good idea
it worked sure but it turns out all they
want to do is fornicate in playing feces
what a waste of time
it'd be great if you found that iridium
Shard because you're the only person who
knows where it is
foreign
[Music]
have stored the iridium in here before
calling it tonight
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
remember the code to her safer ones
better grabs the money for lunch while
I've got this bad boy unlocked did you
say lunch you buying
were you seriously about to scam me
without my consent not cool I'm we
really need to work on your people
skills boss
if you want to know what's in my pocket
ask phone can you tell me what's in your
pocket it's a vaultlander figure some of
the other lab assistants and I like to
play before work I totally creamed
Roberts this morning in this was my
sweet reward
my trusty tools so much potential for
science in these simple implements
and what's that
oh Anu really
[Music]
got you
left the rare and Incredibly expensive
ore inside the toolbox again didn't you
Maybe
foreign
[Music]
it's like it's singing like a siren song
like The Sweet Sound of success not
Financial though I could really use the
money to get my brother off from media
but ethical success
foreign
where we use innovation and Technology
to help people and protect life not
casually destroy it as a matter of
course like like
don't you know I know like profit
focused warmongers with no moral compass
Beyond The Almighty dollar exactly AKA
atlas's motto
no cruelty no killing no compromise
you're a revolutionary boss oh who are
we rising up against
not that kind of revolutionary to me
don't worry
I won't revolutions typically generate a
30 increase in market share good for
business
in fact the only thing better for
business than revolutions are the
vicious campaigns with suppression by
the ruling Elites that inexorably
you think we should maybe I don't know
not root for people who resort to
violence and total upheaval as a means
to an end all people is integral to
progress and file it against violence
which as I mentioned is great for
business
right anyway are you here for something
in particular Timmy yes please I'm here
on behalf of Mr strong Fork to inquire
why our company's test subjects
liberated
I'm sorry test subjects the divers
liberated correct your comprehension
level is impeccable you should have no
trouble explaining why the jabbers are
loose
again
they're currently running a knock down
the laboratory hallways the janitorial
staff is prepping for what I like to
call
why would I know that what even makes
you think I have anything to do with it
I'm not the only one that works in this
lab
what what slag off that soup's uncool oh
Dr Dar we know it was you
but you have no proof the thing is every
use of credentials to access a security
feature is locked we have a record of
your ID being used to open the cages
someone else could have grabbed it
the other thing is our security
surveillance system filmed you doing it
it's any consolation the footage from
this instant was captured at a much more
flattering angle than the footage of you
releasing the jabbers those other times
you know what they say about jobbers if
you lock them in a room with a
typewriter they'll eventually learn how
to fake digital signatures and open
their own gauges from a statistical
standpoint that is unlikely also no one
says that also what is a typewriter
well now that we've got that
straightened out ah Dr Dar you have an
update to your calendar incoming it's an
appointment with Mr strong Fork oh uh I
can check my schedule to see yeah five
minutes now
oh and uh what is it regarding
it's a reprimand session for Mr strong
Fork to reprimand you oh
not that you deserve my help after
throwing me under the bus but you
probably shouldn't go in empty-handed
you know right
sorry and
right
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
school's out already
hey papa journey I can smell your space
calzones from here
thanks uh I need a new name for them
might also need to stop doing that
problematic accent
yeah I know
Miss Johnson did you get a cybernetic
leg that thinks straight fire
[Music]
how's it hanging dude oh you know what
Octavio is a brand new day filled with
handless possibilities and excitement
so I don't like it
you are good eggs who it is
[Applause]
for tacos
ooh do they come in my favorite flavor
please don't say
don't sit Octavia
oh geez
I anticipated your arrival and have been
waiting in a location that would not
obstruct others
Louis what is wrong with you
hiding dark alleys like that I am not
sensitive to disparities in Luminosity
this seemed a perfectly acceptable place
to stand
I acquired the publication you requested
come on
come on
your Biometrics read extreme
disappointment
it's forges super successful 30 30. it
lists the planet's most promising
Innovative entrepreneurs and I'm not on
it again
have you accomplished some extraordinary
business transaction to Warrant your
acknowledgment on this list I survived
malawan's invasion and I'd like to think
that my social influence has kept this
gather after the war left it in damn
near ruins
no would have been a more succinct
answer look I'm working on it why this
list is merely the opinion of other
humans you should not value it
as a machine I find this Accolade
pointless to strive for
[Music]
your silence for lies a hidden human
emotion
you appear uncomfortable
do you need to evacuate yourself
perhaps you are disappointed but look on
the bright side many of these celebrated
humans have contracts on their heads
bivington Bradwick for example had
numerous bounties on his life but no
assassination bot can kill him he is
Rich and important enough that he never
has to leave his home or do anything for
himself
you however are not on this list you're
anonymous unrecognized a nobody this is
beneficial for your survival but not
beneficial for my image
I mean all the best business people have
probably at least killed someone to
succeed something to warn a bounty
anyway
I'm doing whatever it takes to maintain
appearances
come on if there was a list of all the
best assassination Bots wouldn't you
want to be on it no
hey that list forget it I didn't even
want to read it I just wanted to see if
you were
that logic does not make sense that's
because I'm a future business genius I'm
playing four dimensional chess
I'm a sentient computer I'm literally
playing 300 games of four-dimensional
Chess right now
and
I just won
yeah well I'm more dangerous I've killed
963 people you have killed no one
ah another Checkmate and another and I
get it man
despite your erratic Behavior today I'm
in need of your assistance sorry I'm
busy networking innovating shaking hands
after malawan killed nearly half the
merchants in the city we've all needed
to make new contacts this would be an
actual job with money your various
business Concepts like financing
marketing public appeal kid
I'm not busy totally pranked you you
just got Octavio interesting phrasing
perhaps I'll adopt that well that's kind
of my thing but now on to business
matters you will Aid me as you have
before in confirming the names of my
targets before I shoot two eye on slugs
into their brain
you know how to talk you have a mouth
you will prove exceptional hell yeah I
love helping you with your work less I
love money we all love money whatever it
takes to get my business off the ground
do you actually have an idea for your
business
guns
of you
I'm working on it
son of a skank kissing rats ass
congratulations Francine let's go with
it has been 90 days since your last
uncontrolled Outburst of Rage
all right all right
let's make it to 91.
let's get to work
keep providing your ability to maintain
a positive attitude even though a
malaward's face laser designated your
Frogger truck and subsequently reduces
yellow rating by 3.5 Stars
foreign
[Music]
thank you sponsorbot
[Music]
rating is now negative 3.5 Stars
thank you sponsor bot
[Music]
as soon as the insurance money comes in
this place will the good is new
[Music]
morning do not think about your
malfunctioning key or appliances from
which you still owe the TDR Corporation
600 000 Galactic credits
do not think about the fact that these
machines are also licensed from DDR and
thus cannot be sold isn't it your job to
keep me from losing my cool do not think
on the fact that I'm wondering that
stronger flavor is diamonds the interest
on your dad will keep Pace with your
revenue and you shall be forever
drowning in an ocean of capitalist
indifference
congratulations you are not thinking
about it
son of a
you don't have to do this you have a
choice think before you ask
foreign
oh no
oh geez
it has been zero days
I'm fine it's not a backslide
oh it's a backslide all the way back to
Pure animal rights
everything's gonna be just fine
my new slaughter-romatic combat
vegetable knife slices artichokes as
easily as arteries
we're not open yet and
lore
how's business treating you handsome
not bad if there's two things you can
count on promethean's buying it's
bullets and Brew
place looks as Charming as ever
I thought the insurance money was
supposed to come through by now claims
guys come and buy today they've been
jerking me around saying I have to pass
some sort of final interview to get my
cash
how dare they not trust a kind old lady
like you want me to shoot them
it's been a while since I shot anyone a
week at least
still I'm a steady trigger
so long as I've got some caffeine in me
yeah go for it there are precious few
problems a couple of well-placed bullets
can't solve
they teach you that in the military if
they teach you mean repeatedly scream at
me and if by military you mean mom then
yes
right well just tell me who to shoot and
where to shoot them and I'll have it
done by end of business today thanks for
this by the bye samezies
uh oh looks like the morning Rush has
arrived
I'm out here
all right all right all right time to
make the Froggers
good morning welcome to friends Froggers
what can I get you today Han
a large peanutty buddy with sprinkles
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
foreign
here you go sweetheart
whoa this looks incredible friend
I know babe
go
welcome to Mr strongborg's office please
make yourself comfortable while I inform
him of your presence
[Music]
just apologize for the jobbers won't
happen again sir
you cannot lose this job
my idea is a paradigm shift one that
could help Atlas beat the competition
yeah that sounds great convincing job
Saving right
Jimmy don't talk to Darrell I'll see you
now Dr dar
unfucking believable
hello sir uh Mr strong Fork uh is
everything all right because I can come
back if no no no everything's fine it's
fine
it's got a bid again on an ultra rare
zero vote Landers figurine
again
it's an investment you know you know you
know what forget it never mind just just
come on in have a seat
thanks for coming up on such short
notice but I figured I oughta just said
meeting as quickly as possible so we
could touch base on the issue of you
keep releasing jabber's on the ship
again you've got to stop doing that
and also we're in space we're all
contained animals up here Dr dar
I did release them and I'm not sorry
I will not condone and I certainly will
not participate in the needless torture
of animals under the guise of scientific
research a byproduct of a capitalist
system that thrives on violence wait
wait wait wait why does this sound
weirdly familiar oh maybe because I
wrote an entire mission statement about
wait you read my mission statement
oh God the memo that's right yeah they
were upgrading some of the circuitry in
my office and the bathroom door got
stuck
so I had some time I mean a lot of time
to kill and things got kind of desperate
I'm just saying I read every page
that I used
oh God the point is you've proven that I
can't trust you to follow corporate
regulations and what's more
you cost me a fortune do you have any
idea any I have guys in r d working on
Cold Fusion powered giant robots who
spend less money than you've wasted on
freeing animals from their cages and
iridium or oh my God the Iridium ore if
I'd seen any evidence at all a shred a
bit but you had been using that iridium
ore to make something that you know we
could sell or patent or eat I wouldn't
care but
now that is a pretty interesting little
gun there huh
look at it all gun shaped this is no gun
Mr strong [ __ ] this is my
device
okay device gun this device is going to
achieve something no one ever has
something no one has come close to
replicating the powers of a siren with a
pull of a trigger
now that's a pitch keep going keep going
I'm serious this is exciting the cold
fusion robot guys they give a fun
presentation but it's always you know a
little a little much
this is the most powerful man-made
Creation in the world you need this and
you need me ooh assertive that's good
it's wrong but it's good sorry anything
you develop on Atlas property with Atlas
money belongs to Atlas so I don't
technically need you to have that but
like I said that you know the raw energy
that's great
right
okay decent pitch I give it a c minus
enough to not get you fired yet
[Music]
so I'm gonna need a demonstration to see
what this adorable little game changer
of yours can do absolutely sir
schedule into weeks
I'm at now there's no time like the
present right so present but I haven't
it hasn't it's in progress and it
doesn't do anything does it no no it
does just let me explain
[Music]
Oh by all means and by all means I mean
this it better be really really good or
you're fired
[Music]
designed to move any tangible subject
through space-time move through
transport yes it's a phase walk gun it's
a phase walk device a
phaser
a phaser a totally non-lethal utterly
decisive way to end any conflict wait
non-lethal
yes
so to clarify you have spent all the
money and resources at your disposal
that I gave you from my disposal to
build a gun that does not kill people
I've built a device gun device that
doesn't kill it just sends people on a
little vacation
a vacation to death no just a vacation
they literally they vacate our our
customers don't want to send people on
vacation they want to send them to death
okay okay you know what show me show me
or put it on the desk and leave my
office okay I I think you're really
going to like this sir
I am waiting to be deeply deeply
impressed here I mean Florida really at
this point and I
[Music]
oh my God
oh my God
right that wasn't the blast dummy it was
my it was on display [ __ ] it oh my God
oh
okay okay okay impressive it's very
impressive now you know reverse phase
unzap
D eliminate bring it back
there's no reverse with which so it only
does the one thing so far
it's a prototype well where the hell did
it send my stuff I uh
I do not know
so it's just
God
forever
like so many fabric scraps in the Wind
coasting Through The Ether
I'll never see that tie again
I could get you some electrical things
sir it won't be the same
song
CEO of the atlas company I am your
assistant uh yeah Timmy I know then now
is my time to shine
let me assist you wait wait Timmy what I
will go on a quest to retrieve what you
have lost uh
uh Rescue Mission
you would do that
for me of course I would Mr strongford
CEO of the atlas cubby doing anything
and everything for you is literally the
purpose of my existence
yikes yeah well that's a fair point
actually
all right
Dr Dar let's try this again
on Timmy
I'm ready
[Music]
foreign
Timmy
if he doesn't come back you'll be
hearing from me
I think
someday
can I just say
for a gun device that's designed to be
non-lethal that thing is really doing
some damage thanks
you not a compliment
you can't control it you barely know
what it does except that it doesn't kill
things which makes it useless it isn't
designed to kill not everything needs to
harm people I feel harmed I feel very
personally harmed just not in a way
that's profitable
oh my God why
Timmy where are you when I need you most
you've reached Reese strong Fork the CEO
of Atlas Corporation
CEO of TDR why why are you calling me
you know what can you hold on for just a
sec Dr Darr you may go and if it wasn't
clear already uh you're fired but sir
Susan how'd they hanging
perky is every race and you eyes and
limbs all accounted for oh yep all good
over here doing just great better than
was there uh something you needed
[Music]
do you know the drill I can't kill my
targets until they say that full name
out loud and I'm able to confirm its
match against the name in the database
that's where you come in
so you must get my target to save their
full name out loud
I'm guessing from your line of work you
don't have a lot of friends
you are the closest thing I would
consider a friend I do not see you in
opposition to my programming
it might be due to your frail build and
anemic complexion
super
what did they do whoever you're about to
kill a man named Jamison Harwin kicked
his neighbor's pet scapped pup
so the neighbor contracted me to punish
him
well I did the Scag do something to
deserve getting kicked blaming's a
fiction Octavia
it's not that maybe it was self-defense
I said for sure
[Music]
do you have any further questions before
we begin the operation
it shouldn't take long
yeah just one
what's your favorite flower posies
posies posies a single posie is
worthless but they're delightful in a
bunch
posies posies
Jamison Harwin lives in that apartment
complex you'll use the buzzer for
apartment 3 to get him to come outside I
will be waiting nearby with death
all right I guess he deserves it
let's go
yeah who's there
hello if this is some kind of prank I'm
gonna come out there and beat your ass
yeah I got a pizza here for apartment
three what
I didn't order any pizza no offense but
are you by any chance drunk sir
drunk folk order pizza then forget about
it happens all the time think of me as a
present from your past self
I'll be down just give me a sec
well I must admit your methods are
strange it seems to have worked now you
must get him to say his full name before
I can fulfill the contract
no problem
give it here kid
I come all the way down here and you
don't even got it
you better not be messing with me boy I
got a hell of a temper sir I'm so sorry
someone just ran by and stole it right
out of my hands but can I confirm your
full name so I can make sure you get a
replacement
I was really looking forward to that
unexpected pizza and now I really want
it
my name is Jamison Harwin and I want to
talk to your manager
you just got l0u13
did I do it right nailed it
[Music]
Jameson Harwin we hardly knew you but
you did seem like a real bastard
[Music]
well done I have received payment here
is your commission friend Octavia
oh Cash Money Make It Rain
I'm meeting the girl buckles you in
I am indeed in though I still cannot
fathom how you can eat food from a man
who lives in the sewers and befriend
scratch
I use a lot of hot sauce
and that's how Papa